yes Queen yes Queen
welcome to punch-drunk sportswear
winners win we win we win we got Pat's
thirty-one we've already won dude we've
actually the best sports Hawk was
already done and not recorded it really
sucked you guys are gonna get that
[ __ ] gold it's just gonna be crickets
chirping joining us in studio is a
number he is the producer of the hit
show he'll Tony our good friend David
Deary what's up oh hi David a hit show
the hit show some say showrunner some
say produce I'm not sure right now are
you live streaming this no what I'm
trying to promote the shows going okay
all right get some phone calls all right
by the way kill Tony yesterday was
hilarious they had Ron White and the
whole band like Jeremiah they dressed up
as the Blue Collar Comedy game that was
amazing it was Blair here Maya Watkins
is Abby here my walking's is going you
will you will know his name by the trail
of the dead he's a killer
and you know a big part of that a lot of
people in the crowd were saying like you
know they like a huge part of that show
why it's so funny is because I'm a part
of it so yeah only got funny till about
a month ago happy to be here I didn't
hear anything about them happy to be
here guys I want to be here David were
you gonna be any dates coming out I'll
be at home editing some photos I shoot a
lot of film I actually I brought a copy
of the door guy zine that I made I don't
know where it was I shot all the door
guys and Joe that's a pretty funny idea
with film my film camera I got a funny
fing shout story
I can't I'm not allowed to sell this but
I'll give you a copy three well because
it's got the Comedy Store logo yeah so
I'm out of your trunk I mean I could I
could but I don't I just give them the
people for free so you know it's like a
little fun project I did okay so I just
want to show it to people in your
fanbase
thank you Sam Tripoli uh funny you
should ask this Thursday I'm gonna be at
the Sycamore tab and the comedy Dover
and cabin
the dojo I'm dojo of comedy inside the
sycamore town with us
Sam Tripoli Sam Tripoli
Jason TTT Bo Ryan Sickler
Joe DeRosa I'd be a horrible referee to
live in the box and this Saturday night
at the rec room in Huntington Beach pick
up my album a white guy named Chad thank
you for listening
I'm going to be the Sycamore Talon
Chad Zimmerman and on Thursday so come
to that show that'll be good also on the
13th we're doing another UFC at the dojo
I'll be there that's gonna be it's a
great card afterwards and so come watch
the fights with all of us brought to you
by bet TS I bet this I use the code
punch 25 and you get 25 free bucks to
gamble with and put it get involved in
this tournament getting involved in the
tournament and you can look at our
Twitter and get your brackets in their
racket actually you know what I do have
a date can I say it
one date I only have one day April 9th
April 9th I'm removing on April 9th
that's it
April 9th I'm dropping in an ombre trim
and I'm raising money for charity okay
cool that's my only date don't give me a
penalty yeah he should get a penalty
sycamore tavern guys I am which at Zuma
oh my god jump in the penalty again good
heart I'm gonna give it a to two-minute
minor yeah that's a minor to me mopping
flubbing yeah I'm done with your dates
in two minutes the whole fiver slumming
all five again I'm with Chad sumac and
Jason Tebow this Wednesday Thursday race
day at the dojo go grab those tickets at
eventbrite.com and then that whole
lineups great the whole lineup yeah
laughs it goes Gareth Reynold love it
sheds ooh POC Jimmy Florentine Sam
Tripoli Joe DeRosa Jason Tebow Tracy
McDonald ride Sickler and Trevor Kevlar
then ion and then Friday night I am at
the Santa Barbara comedy shakedown with
my good friend Lisa I am Mike Tully
Jake alo and many many more we are at
the bass brass beer brewing Ostrow close
the flubbing good they should rename
their place tongue twisters then
Saturday night it's the shady fox live
at the rec room on jim Florentine Joe
Barney Chad sumac zoom and zoom OCH
myself 10 o'clock show at the rec room
in huntington beach then the following
week i am and it's the waking arizona
tour the tinfoil hat comedy and I myself
Eddie Brown XG Phoenix we are there
March 28th that is a Thursday 7:30 p.m.
at the house of comedy and then Tucson
the following night that is Friday night
we have two one nine one tool March 29th
doors at 7 p.m. show a p.m. and then the
final number because I know drives
everybody crazy I am going to be at
rooster teeth feathers April 4th through
the 7th ok that Thursday night is smoke
them out I'm inviting my friends all my
weed friends that all my weed brand
friends from North Calgary come on
Thursday night everyone's your smoke
weed
the to Friday and Saturday is stand-up
comedy and then Sunday night is Q&A
would say I'm Tripoli
I answer all your [ __ ] questions
alright so go to Sam Tripoli comm for
all those days goddamn oh yeah all the
questions all the questions all the
questions it's a four-day show my god so
four days she all the questions for
daesh it's a lot of questions
hey t-bohhh you got something I'll be at
a Brazilian wax museum next Monday
also yeah hit us up on our Twitter with
questions we're doing our next patreon
oh we don't have to do it what's that
yeah oh I shoot you mean people pay the
big bucks
you gotta pay to ask questions yep or go
to Sam's show or go to same show then
you get all the answers all the answers
to all the questions are we doing on the
time for a Zemon I think that was a two
minute minor you guys are harsh I don't
know mad when you don't do the whole
fiver Brown getting blown up I'm like
doing it for us we're doing it for him
but not everything hold on let's let's
just start with I'm new this is new to
me so I don't know what's going on with
the penalty this bar scared straight
dude yeah I don't want that we're like
ex-cons trying to teach this young youth
that he's gonna end up like us if he
doesn't [ __ ] get no water that water
it's like making him smoke on entire
carton of cigarettes what are some
penalties to avoid I mean flubbing is
bad obviously I contact with us yeah
walking when we talk references being
friends with us Oh talking about chick
name dropping name dropping name
dropping yeah oh D telling everybody how
long you been doing comedy referencing
that you have an album available oh he
did that Chad did that already he did do
that yeah so far all you have to welcome
chad is welcome I'm gonna rain this
thing cuz I still want to speak concert
raining down a [ __ ] penalty Bob write
write write a while likes go a little
crazy
and - wait it's go let's knock it off
muck it off yeah he's a mucker yeah he's
a [ __ ] [ __ ] but so why
did you guys get the pen forget it he
wet himself in the box this time we
didn't even do it yeah you didn't do it
I wanted to he knew he had to go in
there
I wanted to notice he did flub you know
but I'm so new to the penalty button I
didn't want to like just come right out
on the I loved every week you know every
week would had Sam do it does his dates
he doesn't self in a penalty box right
there you're all dates
guys we're at 30 seconds buzz I just
made a new rule I talked to all the
elders new rule
Chad's time doesn't start till my dates
are done Wow I got to do my date then
his time starts okay just check the show
that's half the show guys
[Laughter]
7:00 he's already out of the box what's
he doing whoa hey Chad sit in the box
Chad you have to say it only runs when
you're actually in personating bird
that's a penalty right so why everybody
tell us about your vert ramp so
basically what I'm doing is on April 9th
I'm gonna drop in on a vert ramp for the
first time and what people who haven't
skateboarded you can go on my youtube
and there's a couple videos that explain
it what is vert what is dropping in but
it's basically like the big ramps the X
game ramps and it's just like you go to
the top and you that's how you start you
just you just roll you roll you drop in
yeah and for people who skate vert or
you know skateboard that kind of [ __ ]
it's like you know that's basic but for
someone who has never done it it's
definitely like a challenge can't you
die I could break my arms off for sure
okay yeah sure yes there's an element of
pain for sure if you if you check out
Johnny Knoxville drops in on vert he did
it on like jackass and broke his arms
are you nervous
yeah I'm definitely nervous but you know
I'm also I'm training a little bit
johnny Knoxville doesn't really
skateboard I skateboard it's it's
probably equivalent to someone who's
like a like an average runner run
a marathon it's something like that I
could make it if they had mountain lions
I could make it yeah I could make it I
could also break my arms off but here's
the twist I'm gonna here's johnny
Knoxville check it out so there's a vert
ramp look how big look how big it is
watch I mean that doesn't make me scared
cuz he stepped off the board he didn't
really like if you know sometimes they
threw it I think he's just not a
skateboarder so he didn't just stand on
the board see how he does no no he might
be dead he definitely brought I have a
huge announcement to make
I would die doing that [ __ ] can I say
one more thing about it because I'm
raising money for charity on my
instagram @ MF David Irie there's a link
to a GoFundMe what's the GoFundMe let's
go to go fund me look it up real quick
I'm raising I don't know go on my
Instagram the links on there are no the
exactly guys welcome back to the show
Chad the Zeeman Zuma two penalties
already in this video you're a straight
enforcer just gonna be quiet
I think you're doing great so far and
don't forget you put yourself in the box
um he really only has one it's true
that's yourself up go up go hear that so
you need so I'm trying to raise a
thousand bucks I yeah that's it all
right guys go if your your punch-drunk
[ __ ] royal home somewhere you're
[ __ ] I'm not drunk to the bone go help
out David dear he's always on the show
he's always doing our shows he's oh he's
part of the family so go and help him
I'll throw $10 $20 $5 let's get him to
$1,000 they needs to make this happen
here's what I'm gonna do when I get to
$1,000 I'm gonna challenge companies
I've already got the verbal okay from
companies professional move I'm gonna
I'm gonna ask them to match the donation
if I make it first try so if I land the
drop in they're gonna you know hopefully
gonna like match my donation it goes to
a company called skater Stan they build
skate parks for in third-world countries
I love that pretty cool okay give it up
for David diri thanks for coming on
showed it was yeah thanks man I
congratulate all 9th April night
hashtag ver challenge hashtag Virchow uh
if you're a skater I have a major
announcement oh yeah that's right I am
very sorry oh I thought you're gonna say
you have cancer okay oh Jesus right
after my thing you're gonna say you
can't do that I would definitely be
stealing your thunder I am doing Alice
mania but I'm not fighting Ari I am Pro
Wrestling I'm going to do Pro Wrestling
May
the first weekend in May at Ellis mania
is been announced I don't know if
there's a website or anything like that
but I'm doing it it's myself Mike
Catherwood versus [ __ ] jason Ellis
and [ __ ] Kevin Kraft okay so that's
how we're doing it like Armageddon
okay that's my name I'm coming up in a
[ __ ] Adidas tracksuit some [ __ ]
Jew car Cologne a wife-beater gold yeah
you should definitely be light for
saying like with your car in people's
faces like secret maybe your evil
manager they always have managers maybe
a bunch of trial beer mr. Fuji
you're bobby heenan denis just died in
my building yeah yeah you did you die
right a lot of those wrestlers man they
drop like flies they [ __ ] do it up
though that's bad like and they dream
that's all wrong like a rough life
that's a real rough life though drug and
alcohol but still even that's what I'm
debt to even to the more to the point we
all lived them though all right how old
are you 43 43 so there they all died in
their 50s and 60s so we'll see well I
put I put a thing up on my buddy's uh
Instagram it's it was it was a tag-team
match it was mr. perfect ravishing Rick
Rude verse the ultimate warrior Kerry
Von Erich and Bobby Heenan they're all
dead all five of them are dead Piper
Piper yeah it's a it's a definitely
Roddy Piper it's a rough business I'm
gonna go ahead and say it Hulk Hogan's
gonna die soon
he's my grandmother's neighbor oh
grilling yeah I'm guessing your
grandmother's not black then no she's uh
uh also not alive she's not alive oh but
that he was hurting wise did you say is
or was was oh it's neighbor what a long
time she's gone she's buried now right
oh yeah she's dead as [ __ ] but I mean
she doesn't still live in the house
right no I mean maybe she might be
haunting this [ __ ] she is dead Fox I
mean I guess I mean if you got a shovel
dead [ __ ] dead guys got a boat you
got a boner in a show rest in peace man
I'm China's dead - I forgot about that
it's probably those tariffs did that guy
die - macho man what do you mean those
tariffs China macho man dead as well
he's dead right yeah yeah he's dead he
got like in a corner they can't hang
with us in a trade war Ultimate Warrior
yeah Jimmy Snuka Oh Superfly King Kong
Bundy just died
yeah I'd ride the giant Andre the Giant
hit hard King Kong Bundy yeah he just
died right yeah they say you had to have
16 pallbearers ravishing Rick Rude is he
still alive I already said he's dead
ravishing Rose anybody alive Hulk
Hogan's only alive because they gave him
such an easy road you know I mean all he
had to do with her he dropped like no
one one time he got body slammed John
you know he was greenlit from day one
way he was he was pretty much like it
was a hamper are ya Chris Benoit he
killed his whole family
[ __ ] true he did right yeah yeah he did
Miss Elizabeth I know this whole family
and then killed himself right yeah he
wants praise easy Eddie Guerrero I
didn't know he was dead I didn't know
Miss Elizabeth yeah she died maybe let's
get the CTE to right for sure we're
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] getting
concussed all over oh yeah did the
British Bulldog Davey the big boss man
died 2004 age 41
Oh Owen Hart this is crazy list you fell
from a roof scary sherry any really oh
wow anyone related to the macho man's
dead test earthquake died
I mean course earthquake tie that guy's
had one foot in the grave from day one
Big John Studd died John stow there's
Rick Rude bulldog he was only four years
old
hey you know that Dad does that dude
some random bam bam bigelow dies [ __ ]
Johnny the junkyard dogs dead alright
warrior Hawks daddy no jerk your dog
died flying Brian Pillman play for the
University of no he didn't play for him
come on Eric you know why we never heard
what the junkyard dog was dead but cuz
he's black it's conspiracy and that's
the same same reason Kaepernick's not
playing yeah the way you know Bravo
people is sniffing around Kaepernick now
crush Hercules round Kaepernick I think
the patron Miami was III think I
actually can see him getting signed
why wouldn't who I don't get it lawsuits
over that cleared olive and the owners
are a bunch of rich wonderful never know
what he got for that Oh a lot mm-hmm a
lot yeah they haven't disclosed yeah why
would they that would be embarrassing
for then FL if it gets out how much
money he made I'm sure it's a [ __ ] ton
and by the way the list is still
scrolling I had wrestlers but we're kind
of like Oh Chris Kanyon died
damn and now we're getting towards the
now we're getting a black-and-white
photo it's all jabbers hey Saturday
night job
Oh Moondog spot
I believe you sound like you're being
honest dude what do you think's longer
to listen wrestlers dead or porn stars
that go to dead porn stars Wow can you
guys start turning me on I bet the aside
for all your bent knees go to bet dsi
use the promo code punch 25 you get $25
Betty cash what about all the next dead
wrestler yeah what kind of odds do you
get for the next dead wrestler oh we're
on the same page we got it steroids the
cocaine the steroids the [ __ ] they
live the fun life and you got Nana who
lissandra and - cuz she knits and she
just sits there bothers everybody right
Jesus am i going why is that lady alive
art Bell okay little bird I do remember
him buzz Sawyer I dunno about so area
bruises by the way this will be the
entire [ __ ] episode we will literally
go to ours I mean it's amazing how long
this list I mean it literally just keeps
every von Eric is dead every single
joint the clown's dead
doink the foie there it is it's over guy
we got through doing the clowns the last
one the clown doing the [ __ ] clowns I
think it goes rustlers porn stars comics
well you know you see wrestlers doing
stamp you see wrestlers do important you
see porn stars doing stand-up you never
see stand-up but you do see a comic
doing [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
triply just brought it around he just
brought it around that's a professional
broadcaster listen in memoriam Kent
North I don't real name Ben gray Ben
Israel named Ben gray I'm sure I grew up
in Kent Ohio and drew grande do you see
that that's Ariana's brother
they were escorts and dudes didn't want
them stalking this guy Steve driver
natural causes natural cause
I'll remember that about CV good stuff
sledgehammer he's a wrestler too right
that guy has a monster
this guy's a wrestler till shot him this
is sledgehammer versus King Kong Bundy
WrestleMania - I remember that only on
with Ellie on this sports show at least
you hear that guy had a monster dishes
and cops shut up she was like ten years
old when she dumped him the punch drunk
they killed her because she was an
escort dude she had a monster dick Tim
yeah Yuriy love this is a good group of
girls that were all like murdered in
this very short amount of time do Shia
Stiles okay stop this on her stop it on
her we did a I did a show with Joe sing
Conoco in which he did [ __ ] oh he's
to be known as Joe King and he would uh
I did a seat with a sketch with her I
mean she was so filthy I was like what
is it nephew and we saw another big
screen dude you can't show that my
sister will kill me if he ever sees she
was a super escort dude she's a soup or
a skort did number one escort in LA and
these girls all were escorts and they
basically it was right around the me to
movement and they all [ __ ] like she
was in escort she's a porn star for like
three days and they [ __ ] off to her -
how do I have a feeling this is just the
cast of the naughty show pretty much
what CSI for all your betting needs want
bet on the next porn so it's gonna die
go to bet des I use promo code punch 25
and get that cheddar I mean so much talk
about I guess Jags is not calling in I
thought I was gonna call in but it's all
about the tournament get money going on
the tourney
I have the weirdest thing right now I am
caught between my absolute hatred of
Duke and how I know Coach Kate cheats
like a mother feels that why you don't
like Duke no I don't like Duke because
they [ __ ] up you know these perfect
season well that that goes back deep
yeah
but I also know listen dude when you've
been in LA forever right and you meet
that guy who's on stage is like I love
that bu you're great and you know
offstage is just a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
that's Coach K you don't get that far
without being caught right right bro and
this whole love everybody right you guys
are doing great is [ __ ] his [ __ ]
but college sports is [ __ ] so die on
its busted you know Johnny sent a thing
to me gets busted asking for housing and
jobs for his family at this other school
gets busted nobody does anything he goes
to Duke nobody says anything so the guys
asking for [ __ ] cash houses cars for
everybody at another school but goes to
do cuz he loves the game like blue chips
yeah right so no I think Coach K he's so
decorated though I mean he coached the
dream team well no anybody believe that
these guys write money go to the pro go
to Duke cuz they want a good [ __ ]
year six months education yeah but I
don't see in my head every goddamn
universities gotta be like that right
it's gotta be why they do I singled them
out when they under the thing and nobody
talks about it right they never get here
with any penalties they only bust all
these other schools because ESPN and all
these sports network they they want to
do brand cuz everybody watches do they
don't want it to get hurt yeah it's like
a weird paradox it's like if they if
they break it up then they're then
they're their money you know what I mean
these kids you know I got money
of course but we have this rule where
these other schools are just kidding
annihilate yeah right yeah but the thing
is if they it doesn't matter these
schools are gonna get annihilated anyway
if it's legal if it's illegal what I'm
saying is that [ __ ] Duke in Alabama
don't get a Nile
yeah because always gonna watch Central
Michigan or these small schools so
that's their moneymaker and college
basketball is with the destroying
people's career it is garbage drawing
their [ __ ] I agree programs and now
you're letting this guy get all the
glory
I live it with a I lived with the
Division one athlete who was Penn
State's all-time leading scorer
hmm I didn't know it was it so this kid
sport did he play he played a sport and
he was the all-time leading scorer of
that sport but he would steal my karate
noodles ramen yes because he they didn't
pay him he's not allowed to have a job
he ki they're not allowed to work is he
is he in the process he had a cup of
coffee with a couple summer league teams
and then he went overseas and made a
nice career for himself
yeah banging your mother what's the
story Johnny can you tell it on my mic i
dude I don't even really watch college
sports that much this is such [ __ ]
garbage it's like Paley's [ __ ] I
likes a billion-dollar industry
I like the church and college football
and basketball and it's like I'm
watching this kid some [ __ ] master
yeah and he makes me like Duke like I'm
actually watching too hard I'm with you
I'm stuck I like I wish he could win but
the rest of team loses yeah
I'm fine to wait till he makes it to the
pros to watch him I'm fine with it yeah
I just had a discussion with our
Canadian friend over here and hey and I
appreciate you acknowledging talking to
me no one else I'm just over here on the
couch anybody they won't talk to me and
yes if they're gonna go to the Cavs I go
the NBA is not gonna let that help we've
had our shot they're like you had your
title you have about four teams and hey
I mean they were the mixed up you have
good New Orleans you have the Knicks
that they'd rather send that team to the
only people they don't want to send to
is Phoenix they'd rather send it to the
moles over Cleveland yeah there's
probably will probably go Knicks New
Orleans it should be New Orleans but
they're never gonna send Zion to New
Orleans
they will never send John like you if
LeBron wasn't from Cleveland they would
never sent LeBron to Cleveland yeah that
was the story
so they'll sentence I on to New York
because he's gonna go big you got to go
big with him and with LeBrons decline
right now and I know I mean did you see
that shot against the Knicks deal I mean
he just got swatted I mean his he is on
the decline
happening he is going to if I was him
I'd pull rich Paul side and go we gotta
get rid of these TV shows I have to
focus on this because this year will
determine my legacy I really do believe
that like he said hope he seems great
well but how he's viewed as he leaves
out like look at Dwight Howard bro
Dwight Howard is a Hall of Famer and
he's like Nomad yeah because he [ __ ]
with the Lakers even though he didn't
want go there begged them not to Andy
[ __ ] transgenders I mean dude these guys
get everybody pregnant don't you want a
sex with something that doesn't come
with a child support payment Jeanie buss
I heard was gonna like trade LeBron what
she's thinking but canoed LeBron didn't
realize he's not bigger than the Laker
brand yeah so all these guys in
Cleveland and we'll move on for that but
you hear who the Lakers want to get as
coach who you're gonna die [ __ ] tyloo
Doc Rivers well he's already under
contract with the Clippers yeah but he's
got like one or two year and he wants to
he wants another contract up with these
like know how I hated he'd be if he did
that can't coach unless he has a Danny
aged or Jerry West as a GM yeah Magic
Johnson guys a dude that is thinking
dumb with dumber and Plus yeah I can't
when does it ever work that someone has
taken a [ __ ] like these archaic old
coaches into any team you know what I
mean like the Gruden or the [ __ ] you
know the Doc Rivers or whatever it's
like dude it's never been a proven dude
I wore me all the doc went there get the
[ __ ] I can't see them traveling that far
you you know put his kids in new schools
I just don't see it happening dude if we
can get a different coach I'd [ __ ]
love it dude I hate his defensive I hate
his rotations I just think they saw
shout out the mic Jacqueline for giving
me amazing tickets in an unbelievable
Clippers won against the Nets you watch
I was at the game was crazy it was mean
that's such a gritty gutti team yeah I
also like the Nets dude I feel bad for
them because they finally got their act
yeah there yeah and they're ready to
[ __ ] pounce and then boom Zions gonna
go to the Knicks and gonna lose that
whole [ __ ] City whole [ __ ] yeah well
I mean well what'll happen is because
the Knicks fans are Knick fans yeah that
is a team that they well hell or high
water with first but what will happen is
there'll be a gazillion bandwagon people
when Zion gets there yeah he's I could
see them because you're seeing a lot of
talk about James Dolan selling it I
could see them being like we're sending
Zion to you your your your franchise
gonna be worth more it's ever been sell
the [ __ ] team you're either a sell
team we're gonna find a way to sell make
you sell it yeah because they don't want
that [ __ ] brand ruined mm-hmm
Zions they're gonna like it all time the
Knicks were relevant yeah really think
about oh it's been long since like since
Jordan since it was like John Starks and
Jordan when they were there right there
that's probably lot and then Ewing
before that when Jeff Gant Van Gundy was
coaching yeah you pretty much Ewing it's
pretty much that's the last time when
they were big paper like but I mean they
were a play always in the playoffs and
always a yeah you know it in that Jordan
era yeah but not really but not not like
they were not competitive like seven
games with the Bulls and they were just
like it would just finger roll and roll
out yeah get in dude they went to the
finals twice they did yeah Oh Jason they
played Houston Bronco [ __ ] yeah the
legendary Banco that would happen the
Patrick you who finally gets to the
finals yeah they [ __ ] him a Bronco
chase with AC Collins that's whatever
happened with that anyway
no I was something with a waiter I don't
know bad I mean I'll I'm excited for
this year I do think it's gonna be
interesting to watch as I am Williams
because here's the thing about do they
release the brackets they're really yes
yeah we look him up hey Johnny stop
playing [ __ ] asteroids on your phone I
didn't see oh [ __ ] [ __ ] he's pissed
hey you can the [ __ ] oh why did he keep
calling it as I am William said flubbing
what we call this muck muck her [ __ ]
what was a muck maker monk let's look at
this I mean like Dukes got the number
one seed which cracks me CBS why because
dude everyone's gonna be watching I mean
they won that conference and they were
like number two or three all season long
they have Duke losing in the top 14 they
have Duke losing the Elite Eights of
Michigan State who does for CBS bracket
CBS can kiss my dick okay who do you you
don't know anything do you thinks I
don't want in there I just I don't want
say I want I want I love they have
Virginia winning at all that's not
happening dude of course of course he
does
I'm gonna go with guns Gonzaga are they
in my favorite I would like I like to
see you can saga uh they're number one
right you're right sorry
I was thinking IIIi think Duke is
beatable we've seen it throughout this
season they are cuz they can have that
one game off and like Johnny was saying
earlier before the show when we were
talking this morning that that they're
streaky shooters that whole team I love
you know it's so funny about you Tebow
is like occasionally when you start
doing somebody's impression yeah it
starts like seeping into your regular
talk right you could do Jason Keller and
you could be doing Jason you learn all
the time I don't know where now you are
now literally talking like Garnett right
now you're like who else we got there we
got Dukes number one Dukes at number one
we got number one I'm chillin Virginia
is the number one Carolina's stacked I
mean they got Jerry Stackhouse Antwon
Jamison it's gonna be a it's a good team
I love it so I'm getting far I hope that
Duke gets far just because I want to
watch [ __ ] Zion a lot I mean he's he's
an exciting player to watch what if he
gets hurt again I must say some I know I
don't know [ __ ] about college basket
in the first two minutes no I did okay I
likes Eric using Gonzaga but I don't
watch it I just like Kansai because they
were like they used to be known you know
what you order are they are they good
now ever ever I'm gonna unlike that I
might actually block that guy what do
you say about permanent permanent
penalty box
who who is yeah is this Jonny's Twitter
no you had Chinese meeting this [ __ ] um
I'm gonna go with something crazy I'm
gonna go out on the limb I could see
Tennessee winning it ooh yeah I can see
Carolina getting super deep yeah I mean
deep in them I mean let me ask you guys
this cuz I honestly don't watch it but
are in watch college school I don't
watch college sports not football as
well not really
mmm okay no but let me ask you this you
watch college football or basketball at
all I don't watch college sports okay
let me let me ask you this though okay
ask you know I'll watch a game here you
go to college oh no I did not go to
college
that's yeah that's probably pardon he
was high school sports [ __ ] now let me
ask you this though college basketball
is there do teams that win is it usually
the team that people think is gonna win
like is Duke gonna win this year
no likes fair no it's up in the air
right it's like yeah anybody's I mean
like like Villanova right I think
they're by more so than football more so
than football college basketball is a
crapshoot especially in the tournament
that's why I March Madness is exciting
is it good yeah nobody knows yeah nobody
knows cuz it's the same a college
football that's everyone's like all
these Chooch and then it's usually a
blowout not usually but sometimes
internationally a little easier to
predict in that sense then the one in
two teams and then there's a [ __ ]
blowout like 52 to nothing it's just
kind of ridiculous yeah a 16 has never
beat no one right but still never bad
what last year was the first time in 16
B 2 1 I only know about skateboard and
as a proud proud
State General Studies graduate from the
Mac I am going with Buffalo at six to
win it all
Buffalo a Mac school I don't win it win
it all
what kind of money could I win if I put
$100 on doing it all and win it all holy
said he was good how much I'm not what
are the odds how much money would I win
if I put like a hundred go to bet these
I bet the size for all you bet needs go
there that Buffalo
unlike the worst who's the worst team in
the bracket who's playing longest odds
these playing games
16's what okay so well how much would I
win if I put $100 on North Dakota State
and they want it all $12 what do mean
they won't get no the longest shot
they'll definitely give you odds on it
because that's the worst bet right yeah
definitely take that bet that's like
saying like you know Gary Parrish was
that name yeah he's a basketball insider
he has Duke winning at all
wow what a [ __ ] hot take I know I
kind of can stiii think they will too if
they can stay healthy I got I'm taking
Duke I must say something you're
watching the lives right I am there's an
argument that Zion Williams son that his
year at Duke has changed his fortune
that one at the beginning of season if
you look it up the the rankings of and
Johnny will attest to this he was ranked
third the third player in the draft
right they had RJ Bennett right as
number one Barrett and then they had
little as number two and their giant is
number three that's 50,000 to 100 it's
900 it's 9 it's it's 9999 to 1 dude him
playing a year he put himself as the
number 1
I dunno and it was for him he came back
and played and putting bigger numbers
here's the thing I was triply is he
actually is elevating his status as a
player by playing on this national
spotlight yeah yeah and is it worth it
yeah because what's the worst outcome as
he gets injured I mean if it's a
career-ending injury yeah that's [ __ ]
okay did it since the beginning of why
you're still gonna get I've been
following basketball do you not make no
money guys who are projected Lee number
one got hurt and still whatnot number ie
still looking Kyrie Irving
uh what's that guy's in Cincinnati that
went to Denver and Mel of it game drop
no it's talking well yeah I know I'm
with you totally on that Johnny but at
the same time everybody side dude but
there wouldn't have been Dwyane Wade out
of Marquette if he didn't play all four
years he wasn't that guy that's true too
so but you know you're gonna get you're
gonna get guys that are like that and
there's gonna be guys that have to play
four years at a high level D well I'll
tell you what on the map or and they're
gonna get guys from smaller schools that
have to make a name for themselves three
seasons in a row in the tournament it
really bill or what it really built it
really built trust with me with Zion so
I mean that one year really with me it
really elevated the trust he doesn't
follow college more the integrity of
this guy to say you know what money I
don't care about money I just love the
game he likes one year of Education this
is great guys go does you know he
doesn't got cops this is great go to see
key cop what comes up first these this
is why we love our friends at seeking ok
well comes up first hey we won't go see
some games look what comes up [ __ ] the
Lakers but look it they're NCAA March
manager click on that hey is there any
games gonna be in our area and I said
second [ __ ] week you want to go and
I'm click it that's sweet 16 can we get
a press oh dude I can come to the March
30th man BAM I'll go that
Elite Eight that'll be the Elite Eight
I'll go to lead a day in the Honda
Center in Anaheim yeah is that a any
team for Toronto there ha are the
Canucks in I know what it's like nine
different all right and I'm gonna put my
shot eally right I'll go if you guys
sure yeah I'll go to that buy any
tickets after the game we can enjoy a
nice meal at the yard house I'm Canadian
no no no why are you way up there I bust
out all things comedy credit card first
500 tickets are on Sam that one it 181
right there on the corner not that bad
anyone go to see key calm use the promo
code punch-drunk punch trunk and get fit
what $10 off your first purchase $10 off
your first purchase okay that's way you
go to spring training game those tickets
like five six bucks that's a free ticket
yeah they'll send you back for no they
won't send you back for but the point is
is that these these are cheap help out
are punch-drunk by helping out by
supporting our sponsors at seeking calm
now seeking is great because they give
you the list of they brakes basically
break down are two tickets good is this
a good deal is this a bad all the tears
are good but are they good is this good
deal or is this not a good deal Green is
good red not so good
yeah sometimes you know the red ones are
the only thing that's left goes nothing
you can do go to Berlin right there BAM
look at all those green tickets six six
bucks six bucks that's not like baseball
is the best it is the sport baseball you
can go see for nothing yeah it's great
right nothing nothing nothing nothing
seriously it's great in Bert Kreischer
put him Bert Kreischer let's see how his
hole it's all red Hey look at that dude
now to eight wise to 18 so big why is
what Scott's in so much
let's call bird find out why
no oh [ __ ] sold out 2:35 to Seibert dude
I'd pay third
dude he's dude that guy's killing on a
level we don't even understand I mean
that's how you hear something you can't
understand oh cool man Chuck D with
Flavor Flav I know you can't really come
on so go to our friends and see keep
their rates right
they are send off hey right now on
network solution suggested I'd buy the
domain Sam Riverside calm that's what
they suggest I don't know why to make on
you Sam Riverside though I was gonna
tell you this Fang Chow story so he I'm
hanging out with my friend and Fang
child comes up door guy door guy Tommy
door guys everything right there let's
show moving chalice
yeah the chairman of the board cover the
book you know a shaman at the board
hilarious comic good friend of all of
ours and he's got a you know pretty
heavy Chinese accent and he's telling me
I have sex with girl other night I come
in hurt then I spit on at it that's just
dirt talk and now I can't stop seeing
dirt talk that's real dirt talk a lot
more for sure some we all gotta get out
more I gotta get out more
some point you gotta go out and Jim in
punky got him a punky go on the road all
the time Chicago for a long time
that's like burgers rush hour a [ __ ]
comedy right there she's a black
hilarious straight Chinese she's so
[ __ ] insanely hope so totally agree
alright guys that's a great show what
else you guys want to talk about I mean
a lot of [ __ ] NFL moves been going on
to me about it yeah maverick taught me
who have you gotten eagles picked up
[ __ ] man I've been done [ __ ] maybe just
a couple d offensive linemen but
we gotta pay our guys why am I suddenly
blanking well they they sign some of
their their their own guys but oh I know
I'm blank I have to do a baseball
announcement this is coming out oh yeah
this is my count are about to finalize a
contract worth 430 million dollars over
12 years
oh my god I know yeah I'll probably
guaranteed oh of course it is oh he's
probably gonna win the World Series
well that was like the Phillies just
signed abre sorry oh that's even quicker
but I like my like 350 that's what I'm
saying that's what that's what
piggybacked you know the Mike Trout
thing cuz they sign love it was the
title of it I mean like dude Wow - loved
it
Dodger tickets just went up on our good
friend is that C cake he's not your
ticket you know the angel he's never won
a playoff game and Angel not even close
you said you say with the Dodgers okay
I would love a few sadako to every game
man they may never ever sort of make you
sad again with that contract but is
worth he's the best he's a baseball
player yeah so good I don't think it's a
wonderful city but when you're king of
Southern Cal yeah why would you go to
Philadelphia like sunshine blue size and
Asian chicks everywhere why would you go
and have you been to Philadelphia
have you been to Anaheim it's like it's
kind of a no-brainer all right
you're like you're the king also you
could buy a private jet and fly to
Philadelphia anyway now you're living a
[ __ ] gay community best-looking
people around you all are happy because
they're all rich the sun is shining
every [ __ ] day you are living in a
Republican a Republican County in
democratic California where everything's
clean as a whistle
everyone's happy
it's legally they must bleach your
[ __ ] every [ __ ] rape rape is legal
yeah it's a state law is it I think it
Monster Energy Drink flows out of the
taps in your bathroom I wish the
Phillies I'm a I'm a Phillies fan
obviously that would be crazy but I mean
they're looking decent this year hitting
the ball on his ankles he's on the
ground like that and this might come
back and probably gonna [ __ ] [ __ ]
them you know how it is I mean when
you're comfortable it's like you just
got paid four hundred and thirty million
dollars are you really gonna work
[ __ ] hard because yeah but are you
going to work that I mean how much
pressure do you really have dude it's so
fun that's God the Congress retrospect I
called it the Conor McGregor effect what
has he done since he got 120 million
dollars remember Mike Tyson when he
fought Lennox I see pictures of him
working out I got his Instagram he has
photos of him working out and then he
said thanks for the [ __ ] this is the
guy who was fighting he said let's do it
again
Hey Dude he would fight every nine
months i if you if you have Mike Trout
walk out into any random City and ask
anybody just walk - wait who is this guy
how many people do you think could name
that that is Mike Trout I mean depends
where you are if you go to like Portland
Oregon yeah probably not so yeah why not
that many Oh
Milwaukee Wisconsin more people because
they probably watch bass okay put it
this way if he put if he had a suit and
tie on the floor if he didn't have a
baseball hat on and a baseball uniform
people wouldn't know the funky with his
last name on his back right well we were
we were standing next to Baker Mayfield
and I I'm a [ __ ] Browns right right I
didn't know who he was he's I would
recognize Baker Mayfield yeah but I
think I would recognize more and if I
can pray by him I know I didn't even
know anybody follows him he started
sucking his dick yeah yeah yeah man too
bad he didn't have the penalty box
button for this rock walked into the
Comedy Store yesterday right out buck
right yeah walk right by me we're like
Chris Rock yeah and he's like you know
amongst us up there oh yeah totally
hates him
why
what sounded like name-dropping but i
didn't want to hit I don't want to hit
the penalty no name drops like I know
him that's my dude I cannot believe you
just said that dude
it was totally relevant to what we're
talking about whether you can recognize
a pro athlete or not that's true he
wasn't conversation Johnny get panel
taco are you throwing Johnny in the
penalty sounds like it I need is [ __ ]
what he's above and beyond penalty oh
yes he's the coach though he works the
timers that's why I can't go in there
yeah who would time himself that if you
talk Johnny and then you throw Johnny in
the penalty box it opens up a black hole
the Eagles got to shawn jackson by the
way yeah i like him coming back yeah
bored already rams put them over the top
bortles
yeah nick foles to the jaguars that's a
good one whatever it is we'll see I
think we'll see who he really is a few
yeah we will or not cuz he has no one to
throw to either guys no one to throw a
DS Louis yeah who is it it's I think
it's a wide receivers coach or something
like that it's not one of the it's not
one of the big the coach coach is uh was
the offensive coordinator and Colts are
gonna be good and ran the QB coach back
then I can't remember Browns are begun
fellas we're the most exciting team in
the league right now yeah Kansas City
Chiefs everybody here who you hear
talking about the Chiefs and who do you
talk about the Browns
but that's not what we're saying what
we're saying is everybody's talking
about Oh gallop ankle and and Landy and
they play to college together at Ella's
yeah they work out again they're like
best friends yeah it's gonna be fun
and they got [ __ ] favorites with
North Korea hunt
yeah cream Han cha any only got eight
games which I predicted last week on the
show I'm like he won't get more than
eight games three weeks ago I was in the
valley getting sushi we walked right by
maker Baker Mayfield
and Baker Mayfield if you recognize him
you I didn't recognize him at first Sam
did then I asked for a photo and he said
they're gonna win the Super Bowl there
you go
it's unrealistic we were oh in 16 in
2017 so this is amazing that we can
we're favored oh it sucks and it gave up
your bro peppers in that trade Jabril
why who's he the starting safety was
great I loved him
oh they gave up the they gave him him to
the giant sir yeah that was all Beckham
so he'll be like he'll be there starts
decent he's real good yeah it was
awesome
I didn't know they gave up player player
swap yeah I just get picks up yeah him
and whatever picked again I don't know
what the [ __ ] that Jess was there first
I don't know what the Giants are doing
that's insane to give up Odell Beckham
he's basically their money Oh Dell
Beckham and keep Eli right it's like
you're gonna get him you got ship out
Eli yeah you got a ship it's so dumb
this year when it's like the quarterback
Draft is like no and void it's like well
Buffalo come come come come come
I don't know the Giants are just [ __ ]
horrendous his phone was recording
everywhere saying he was just doing like
voice too tight so I just kept income
[ __ ] up is it's like a huge paragraph
of everything we've just said what are
you trying to do Sam what what are you
trying to do
he's trying to take over the world yeah
Cass called [ __ ] business dawg okay I
didn't know what it was called
yeah having hunt having a hunt to is I
mean an eighth game so he'll be back
like October right right and he'll be
fresh no I don't know the Browns are
gonna be good they'll be fun to watch no
those Raiders whose Raiders will
probably win it
Raiders Raiders no [ __ ] around we
don't even have the [ __ ] draft yet so
we don't know what the hell's gonna
happen when is the draft actually middle
of April and where is it this year it is
most felis it's a little OCD a list no
we're like it's in silver yeah it'll be
good in Dallas 20 bucks for coffee
a hundred percent have it here
when opening one's the opening day of a
major league baseball one's done like
two weeks or something though it's like
10 days
when's Dodgers first 128 Wow so buddy
everybody's so excited about nothing are
we going yeah I want to go let's go now
it's like $12 I'm making Chetta
last year I bought a really cheap seat
and I went there early and I sat right
behind home plate and then I stayed
there the whole game I don't even want
to talk about how I did it but I stayed
there the whole game I I found like four
seats that were empty and just stayed
there and I watched a Aron Ola pitch
against Kershaw oh it was [ __ ] so
good it was like a box or something I
will never get that time back from that
story I am was great I'm excited about
baseball I don't know I am too how much
I like going to games now
all-you-can-eat section at Dodgers team
is great yeah I've seen it but I haven't
like some HGH pills because I take HGH
pills - yeah of course
shredded oh yeah and I was walking and a
Leawood Highland there is a Dodger store
and I'm like I'm not going there see if
they have any weak little island oh yeah
Dodger store and I'm like I'm gonna see
if they have a pleat Jersey because it's
probably worth they'll probably selling
it for nothing I went in they had one XL
left I go how much like 40 bucks I got
$40 normally cost 140 and you were
making fun of my story what the [ __ ] you
bought a [ __ ] Jersey great story dude
I bought a Jersey I went to a [ __ ]
Rams game and there was this dude
selling a t-shirt for ten bucks man I
bought a [ __ ] Rams tee unofficial on
the road you know and I helped the black
community out you know I supported the
black community do you like one one time
I went to an Indian's game I saw Corey
Kluber pitch like six innings and
like bought the ticker for $15 and he
just pitched all six innings that's
[ __ ] amazing love this instant
feedback that's a paid story man that's
who's that Jameson
Jim Jefferies calling in or Florentine I
tech support yeah yeah was that a name
drunk I wish she'd given Jefferies is
[ __ ] Cullinan I know what if he calls
in he just has like the most boring
story about all the work he's doing in
the community suddenly this guy loves
people
Panthers saw that he's I mean he's no
spring chicken but he'll get you five
okay there we go what are you doing
we're going to the Brody Stephens
hotline on the phone right now
from Jersey how are you Lauren teen
buddy how are you
can hear em hear us Jim yeah where you
go guys broadcast not a chance
no I'm off his [ __ ] phone cuz Chad
didn't give you a number to the studio
okay okay
hey Jim call this number what's the
number that's like a penalty 3 2 3 2 a 2
7 4 2 4 okay call that dude it would be
much easier 7 4 2 5 2 4 he's gonna he's
gotta text it to you two minutes Chad
two minutes got two minute or Chad zoo
monk
two minute or dude really did it to
yourself
really did it by [ __ ] producing
horribly
huh you'll be a producer on the show I
would feel like that would be a
five-minute major and the clubbing is a
two-minute minor you guys are really I'm
not saying I do I'm just I'm just I'm
just trying to figure out how it works
around here you know that like a pillowy
that seemed like a real heart we're
trying to figure out this [ __ ] - yeah
like a serious penalty to only get a two
minute for that but hey whatever you
know we're trying to figure this whole
[ __ ] out as well how old is the penalty
it's pretty new oh you've been on the
show but it's just giving it a test
drive and it's going pretty good so what
has he been on here for like a month now
some month old about a month they
penalty but the penalty box follows chat
around iron I assume I assume that he's
leading the league ever been in it
sometimes when he's doing hello
yeah I'm here seems much more efficient
there we go there we go are you Jim
Florentine somebody word I'm getting
surprised that I couldn't it couldn't
sound good through Chad cell phone yeah
Chad [ __ ] it he's got the iPhone
negative for well yeah he said that will
patch me through on my phone I'm like
how is that gonna happen yeah yeah Chad
it didn't the worst the worst dude hey
write down this time that he uh he
called in please the time ready to give
it to Johnny so dude are you excited
you're coming out we got two shows we
have a late night Thursday at the dojo
and then the four of us myself Chad zoom
ah Q and Joe bartnik will be doing the
the new rec room that's out here that
everyone's kind of playing it's kind of
a place you play when you want to do a
road gig in LA it's a nice spot I can't
wait man I'm in LA probably like four or
five months now for some reason and uh I
always love doing shows with you guys
and you know it's gonna be awesome
I can't wait well unfortunately the gang
can get get the back together because
you know Brody was part of the social
justice warrior team and you know you
guys kind of got super close when we
work together and it was like didn't we
just enjoy like how much you like Brody
loved two things on the road and that
was Alex Jones and hardcore pornography
subway it was so much fun like he was 30
watch enforce or watch like chicks
taking on 90 dudes [ __ ] there was a
lot of fun man
man that was such a great trip
you know us for we did San Antonio and
usin all I just hang in thin air B&BS
and busting balls and going on the radio
it stopped it was great - and it's
[ __ ] we loved him and what's like so
I'm glad we're getting the band back
together we have a little Brody Stevens
moment with us all together but we're
getting so we're gonna be at the rec
room this Saturday night come down it's
gonna be four powerhouse people Giants
are your Giants fan right or either
Dolph oh your dolphins that's right I
mean you're from the Jersey area oh by
the way Tiff's is great man I know you
live near there I just did Tess we sold
out the first show the second show was
half packed and it was a that's a fun
room to play man yes the little shitty
gig in Jersey upstairs I've done it like
three times
I enjoy five minutes for my house and
I'm like I want to work on an hour of
material and it's the perfect place to
do it right dude you need those rooms
where you can just [ __ ] work on [ __ ]
work on [ __ ] but back to the Dolphins
are you excited they got rid of Tara
hill he needed to go you know what I
mean he's a good dude and everything and
he's a good guy a team player but he
just doesn't have it he's not you know
he's not gonna take you to a Super Bowl
and they waited too long and I just kept
you know buying into it that he was
gonna you know get to the next level he
just never did
well I only need to tank for a season
and then we'll see what happens I mean
they signed Ryan Fitzpatrick because
they want to be a boss but you never
know it I can I get hot for a little bit
and then he talks no no everything's
gonna be good for six games for six
games you know [ __ ] he's gonna win six
games for you guys and then they oh yeah
this is free chill and they shut him
down but the first six he'll put up not
like dude so he's put up like numbers
better than Troy Aikman in some games
he's been like Hoth Fame hot the first
six games he crushes and then they just
go oh yeah let the Eagles up last year I
remember that I mean he absolutely lit
the Eagles up for like six touchdowns or
something
and then they like you're talking about
maybe Miami getting this [ __ ] kid out
of Oklahoma what's his name um Kyle Mari
yeah would you like that 5 foot 10 guy
well I would want him I mean but he's
not the man he has no shot again no he's
gonna go number one number one they're
gonna fire actors how about I got no
shot would you guys go and get on the
kid that they drafted last year Arizona
what's his name um Tebow gosh that's
rosin yeah would you go get him third
round pick I would definitely take him
and see what happens
I think the dopplers are banking on 2020
with tour coming out and all these other
great quarterbacks but you don't know
what's gonna happen Ryan Fitzpatrick is
gonna be six and ten they're gonna draft
11 next year yeah and there's gonna be
four teams in front of them they're
gonna take all these great quarterbacks
Yossi knock and you can't trade up you
can't trade up so you're screwed
yeah they said the Cowboys are in talks
for Dolphins defensive end Robert Quinn
he's good but they don't need them you
know they're rebuilding so he's
expendable if you get a fourth around
fourth or fifth round pick form take it
definitely so would I hope that one of
the team's takes them what's your take
on what the Giants are doing right now
where they're like got rid of Odell
Beckham but they keep [ __ ] but Eli it
just makes no sense well all Dells
you know he's up he's a major problem
for teams yeah because I'm like no your
typical diva receivers who Co causes
problems in the locker room and you know
it's smoking weed down in Miami in one
day off before we start the playoff game
with Justin Bieber you know yeah Justin
Bieber you ever see that video out boy
never see the video where somebody walks
in on Justin Bieber blowing Odell
Beckham what yeah yeah it's a weird
[ __ ] video on podcast ever hug
welcome to homo rock slowly bleeds into
each other is Eli a hall-of-famer
yeah of course you went to Super Bowls
you're a whole
crazy points in the Eagles fan I'm like
oh don't make me say it but he's
absolutely oh yeah already Hall favorite
Chad absolutely I mean all he has to do
Baker Mayfield you meet him what do you
bring that up Baker Mayfield can play
with his left hand next season will
still go to the playoffs damn Browns fan
select a Jets fan they get coffee too
haven't done anything yeah remind
offseason exciting how do you think the
Jets are going to do now they got that
running back I mean they don't be better
Damned Arnold those USC quarterbacks are
never good in the NFL so you don't know
I mean tiny hands Donald it's got super
tiny owners about the NFL just notice
about the NFL there's never been a team
that stocked up on under on free agents
and trades with big-time players that
did well the net that year the Redskins
tried it a bunch of times on a Deion
Sanders Bruce Smith and like six other
guys it never works out yep so I'm not
buying in on the brown yeah I did we're
not buying in on a bra hey speaking of
the Jets fortunes good friends with had
Adam GaSe well I'm just throwing it out
there
oh yeah yeah that's crazy because he's a
huge fan of yours and now he's the coach
the Jets oh you're gonna be able to go
and hang out there watch those games my
most hated franchise a guy that I became
friends what goes to like that's how the
most hated franchise in all sports as
the Jets so now we text each other he
goes I don't know if we could be friends
anymore
alright go back I go I know I go it's
like you're [ __ ] my ex-girlfriend
yeah so how was your time in Florida
Florentine do you get busy I was nice
yeah Florentines a good man he goes out
there is just a man's man man's man
yeah he goes out there he lets ladies
know who goes out there yeah goes out
there man go out there real men go out
there just goes out there looks ladies
know who's running the show he's out
there yeah
Hey ladies I'm out here
in stray so what's gonna happen with
that that metal show everybody seems to
be wanting to get it back on TV yeah
exactly people that don't know how TV
works want to get back on TV Jim you
should just put it on Netflix yeah doing
it would actually be a dude it would be
perfect for Netflix okay so what do you
want me to do I mean it you know I you
know like when it went when two Sopranos
ended do you think people going around
together FINA go come on
what about Netflix you got to admit
though you got to admit another season
of Sopranos would sell well on Netflix
well they're gonna do move I know your
dad like what do you do without the guy
who don't like the you know the prequel
you know yet it yeah no I know but you
know look the network owns the show that
you you know yeah if the fans loved it
that doesn't mean that it could go
people like what you doing on YouTube
like okay great
so alright it's about you know 32 people
at work for the show so raise those
people look man we don't need reality
injected into our life man we want to
believe what we want to believe just put
it on YouTube they are they are bringing
Crank Yankers back though they did an AR
yeah i don't know what's the information
who's gonna be on like a TV on guys on
Comedy Central right I mean they it's
their show oh it's so funny you know
twenty new episodes on Comedy Central oh
that's great see Comedy Central so it
must be realizing hey the the stuff that
people like is the [ __ ] talking I mean
it's part of it and Jim's a lead puppet
right there look we have it on the
screen that's that special ed yeah I
think Todd Reese made those puppets no
no that was the whole thing like in Jim
still do special ed in 2000 I do super
special II love dead no they changed the
name to [ __ ] as [ __ ] to characters
on the show I know I'm gonna be back on
it I don't I haven't heard anything I
just know you know I'm definitely part
of the reboot so we dude that's sweet
I got a new dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] ed
that's what if they're gonna call it
again
that so you just took his job and
[ __ ] that's a real one worse the
crime the less the penalty what's going
on over yeah he got five guys later is a
tavern right yeah wait up plagiarism he
only gets one man what would you do this
Colosseum 32nd can have that seem like a
vicious penalty that seemed like a real
like like a [ __ ] like a high stick
and blood coming out you know and it's a
one-minute penalty I've never even heard
of a one-minute penalty half a penalty
that's the first one ever that's a one
minute oh he gave them two minutes
anyway okay disobeyed you Johnny make an
executive decision as I like it we have
to put your friends penalty box Chad is
really out control on the show lately so
the only way we manage it by throwing
him into a penalty box
Jesco sit in a chair and listen I don't
I don't want to be wrong here but I'm
pretty sure that uh this uh this
graffiti writer from from New York
Todd Reese made the puppets on Crank
Yankers okay my shoutout Todd Ricci is a
great artist if he didn't make the
puppets and I'm wrong whoops but he's
still an amazing artist REI yes when'd
you get in town Jim I'm coming in
Thursday afternoon Thursday I've seen
Jim are you our NCAA guy at all no okay
no I have it takes too much time out of
my life are you a baseball man baseball
and football what do you what'd you take
some baseball right now well I love that
Mike Trout got that huge contract Jesus
Christ LARP authority is gonna be the
highest-paid player in the league and
that lasted a week yeah I [ __ ] [ __ ]
price huh Mike Trout is the [ __ ] though
definitely I'd rather have Mike Trout
than Travis an animal Bryce Harper did
not want to go to the Phillies he had no
choice he really didn't want to play in
Philadelphia but they offered him the
most money and he thought who's gonna
get 400 million and he's not because
he's a streaky player yeah and the trout
is just an tribals way better than
a low-key guy plays in Anaheim and
doesn't seek the spotlight at all and
you know he's the best player in
baseball by far
yeah he I mean dude and it just sucks
cuz he'll probably not go anywhere with
the Angels I mean I know where he's
going to the bank with 430 million
dollars but he's not gonna compete for I
mean they're just not going to be able
to I know they're opening up a new arena
I think they're gonna try to move closer
to LA because they really wanna be an LA
team than being a hind tear say there
yeah they want to get a new stadium
we're closer to Los Angeles they could
build one right near me I live in
Hollywood yeah homeless Depot where you
live there's a couple like parking lots
I think they probably go to Inglewood
everybody just wants to go to Inglewood
you're gonna have a football stadium a
basketball arena and of a baseball field
and the fan and the forum and the forum
who's crying about everybody new moving
closer that I went to
what's your team what's your team Jim I
like the San Francisco Giants and
baseball one of the best baseball
stadiums you could ever go to the new
one of the old one Jim we should do some
kind of shows this year up there somehow
and go watch game I bet that's that
giant Stadium is amazing I've been there
bunch of times
I would love to so there's this very
famous Canadian commoning Gerry Dee and
he was really nice to me when we did the
San Francisco Comedy Competition I was
so broke I couldn't afford a hotel so he
let me crash on his floor and one day
he's like dude I wanna go watch I want
to go watch a Giants game see Barry
Bonds so I'm like let's do it so he
bought me a ticket
this is name-dropping isn't it I'm sorry
about my show okay so we go we go we go
to the game and he goes I'm a bi you
want hot dog I'm like I'll take when I
go he's like okay I'm gonna go so some
reason he walked your hot dog as soon as
he does that Barry Bonds walks up and
hits a [ __ ] home oh wow you've never
talked to the guy stance on no I came by
goes oh my oh yeah goes I'm just gonna
tell my story well that brings up an
interesting point cause listen
bill simmons podcasts and we're talking
about the Major League Baseball Hall of
Fame and how ridiculous these guys
horrible why isn't Barry Bonds why
aren't these guys in the Hall of Fame
when you got the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame Michael Jackson a child molester
still in there what's your take on that
Jim well you know those old crusty
sports writers 75 years old or whatever
like that they're just old school guys
that don't think anybody in the
seventies did any kind of steroids did
any kind of advantage and they all did
they also served a game caught him up
and they were doing steroids in the 70s
- they just didn't get caught they
[ __ ] Carranza with coke before the
games a Dave Parker so for some reason
they hold it against bonds and Clemens
and the guys that did roids
meanwhile Ricky Henderson's in the you
know in the Hall of Fame and you know he
did and I'm sure Frank Thomas and all
those other guys that did to Frank
Thomas have built like a friggin truck
you know who didn't I guarantee opposite
field home run you did steroids when you
do that I can griffey jr. he's the only
guy I think didn't do it because his
[ __ ] he would just hurt the whole time
like the guys is it Roy
yeah because that's no because that's a
side effect from doing steroids that you
break down so he definitely did okay
point 100% he did him guaranteed yes
yeah well because you don't have the
guys that always get caught with the a
two-game suspension or like little
little middle relievers or little second
baseman's and stuff like that you don't
have to get really big it depends which
one you take so Griffey didn't have to
blow up like Sammy Sosa or McGwire you
know he could have just taken a mild
version of them I mean people in
professional sports are always trying to
gain a little bit of competitive
advantage I mean it's it's whether
they're cheating by looking at other
teams playbook sore
filming the other thing you ever had
just access advantage access to
everything of course
the best doctors the best drugs the best
everything I mean what's the difference
between like a steroid or like just an
incredible painkiller that you can shoot
up into your [ __ ] leg and go back and
play in the right advantage absolutely
absolutely it's just kind of like just
let them do it all and [ __ ] let's
watch some amazing [ __ ] homeruns so
Jim okay what about Pete Rose do you
think he's allowed in should be in oh
yeah well
you know I did for a long time but then
you know when it came out that he
actually bet on the red - but he said he
always said he bet to win on the red
which is kind of like okay so you're
keeping a starting pitcher and longer
even and then maybe in a few days he
won't be able to pitch the next time
around or for a couple days because he
did that and he may be arrested this guy
but not that it's kind of I say should
be in but he did some shady [ __ ] by
doing happy but being the manager of
betting on your own team I mean he also
[ __ ] miners so that was a big thing
you enjoy doing was banging like 50 year
old chicks did he well maybe they look
17 Czech Republic maybe was in the Czech
Republic I think 15 is the legal age
everybody everybody did that back in the
70s everybody had 14 year old
girlfriends all the rock stars and all
that stuff that's what they did that was
the time back then what people they said
as she goes either 14 or 15 in 1973
that's a little young I like how they
they're not quite sure it could go
either way
well to look at you know Jimmy Page
dated a fourteen-year-old although
Zeppelin guys The Rolling Stones all
those rock stars in the 70s David Bowie
did just came out these two girls said
they yeah had a threesome with him they
were 15 years old so that's what they
did back then so just you know you can't
just erase all out of history and just
say they're all bad some with 15 year
olds they're doing working year old out
on tour yeah I mean it's just like so
[ __ ] weird and we get really mad at
Michael Jackson because well I'm not mad
at him dude Michael Jackson was [ __ ]
he's two minutes through Michael Jackson
was [ __ ] kids like Leonardo DiCaprio
[ __ ] women like he was he was totally
grooming him bring him back to the yacht
he dumped him when he was done with them
listen this is why I know about Michael
Jackson he loved
non-union kids sag vouchers that's why
he was into he never [ __ ] the stars
only the extras and the [ __ ] best
grips and I haven't even watched the
documentary well you got as here's I
think it's kind of like who didn't know
this [ __ ] was going like it's horse
rehash it's like [ __ ] day like I mean
you can prevent it by having a ugly kids
or ugly up your kid when you send it out
rub dirt all over him maybe hey Jim did
you ever have Michael Jackson on that
metal show no we did it look I feel I
was feeling up he'd like a young chatot
and like nine years old just out of the
blue eyes is all overcast is that like
oh yeah your mom would be like anybody a
father figure in this kid's life
feel free to lick his [ __ ] oh yeah I
was perfect would you have fallen for it
go hang with Michael Jackson Chad would
you have fallen for could he have
groomed you well that was the thing like
he was so powerful cuz I don't think
there will ever be anybody as famous as
Michael Johnny phones do you have again
you had now you have more than one
really famous yes and I didn't have
guidance so there's a good chance I
would have [ __ ] Michael I mean I don't
I'm I'm not into it but there's a good
chance a young a hero impressionable
confused you're getting cotton candy
going on Ferris wheels private jets my
dog Polly a man two months ago Chad jerk
me off tickets a magic shop does he make
you make eye contact so it doesn't feel
weird no I just I killed it just look
straight ahead or brown fat on it
[Laughter]
all right Florentine dude I'm so excited
to be getting with you will see you on
scene wait Jim you got a special coming
out right
tell us about it real quick oh yeah mark
March 29th I got the house yeah up on
iTunes video audio wherever you get us
how many sad what's it about
tell us what's the don't [ __ ] such a
piece of [ __ ] I know I'm here okay uh
what's the college called everyone is
nobody calling I got the house and what
you did it at where'd you do where'd you
shoot this to a small crowd which I love
this I love when people shooting in a
small crowd I think that's the best way
to do special yeah Anthony comeö studio
in New York City I would film there for
35 people Wow 35 that's the way yeah
that's great
why go [ __ ] is big 35 that's Jim also
got some book called everyone's awful
except for you you can get on Amazon or
wherever your books well cuz you know
it's a Volvo that might divorce so it's
more like a personal piece it's not like
a one-man show but I just like I don't
need a big audience for this and he had
the studio and all the cameras and
everything I'm like why not just shoot
it here I brought my own chairs to the
special to put them down Chad was with
he had opened a special for me so I
brought my own chairs for my house and
put them down for [ __ ] people who
said I love you I love you furniture is
special I think that's awesome know that
cuz there's no crowd shot so I didn't
care for the look shitty might be my
lawn chairs it almost seemed like vh1
behind the guard that you know those are
MTV Unplugged with the band like Nirvana
I got a fast car alright Jim you're the
best do I look forward to seeing you
buddy this oh it's always fun to get my
own we'll do it again soon see this week
everybody
I see if there's anybody by jim
Florentine we talk some basketball I
know I'm psyched on the end as a Sixers
fan oh good are you kidding me it's
gonna be so stoked I dude I don't think
I honestly dude I think people are
sleeping on Denver I think they're gonna
be
better I think they got I think they got
all the tools to [ __ ] bang with
Golden State I don't know I know about
that now cuz you're now gold I know
about that I doubt it he's bought up as
soon as the playoffs start they just
turn into a difference I don't think so
do nah not this year they say every year
they don't say they're all crazy
thinking that the NBA is caught up to
the ward now they're the best version of
that except for Denver
I think Denver has so many weapons I
think definitely way bigger threat than
[ __ ] Houston way bigger threat than
Houston I don't know man I just I don't
know I don't sit in the West it just
feels like it's just Golden State's to
lose they just they're just gonna wake
up they just kind of like wipe their
shirts off and just go to go to work and
just break everyone the Clippers have I
think 11 games to go and they need nine
wins to get to 50 how crazy would that
be Jerry
[ __ ] West considering the Bucks have
52 wins right now and they have the most
wins in the NBA crazy dude very a seed
in the [ __ ] West is 11 games behind
the [ __ ] number and see me a bit okay
what's up let's go to the phones
hey guys oh yeah a little bit yeah talk
about this Mike Trout freaking 12 year
contract oh dude oh breaking news what
what happened with Mike Trout what's
going on he's going on at my trial I try
got a new deal on extension there twelve
years how much Gatorade deal come on 439
what the Phillies room what the Phillies
yeah Phillies who get the [ __ ] my god
get the [ __ ] trial the Angels oh my
god are gonna go to the
laughs oh my god baby what's your name
dude okay j-just broke news out holy
[ __ ] JJ quickly put this clip online
breaking news
Jay Jay Whaley it's a prank call
where you from Jay Jay from Anaheim
[ __ ] news he's like the Brian Hurst
of [ __ ] smart trial he they called
the Connie Chung of sports breaking news
everybody
Jay from Orange County just broke news
that Mike Trout signed a [ __ ] 12 year
443 million dollar deal damn it wasn't a
penalty by the way that was good yeah
you know Yahoo Sports is reporting he
just broke this news okay he broke the
news of Yahoo's broken thank you Jay we
appreciate you man thank you so much
hope to see you [ __ ] April 13th live
at the dojo
inside Sacramento because you broke Jay
listen to this because you broke the
[ __ ] news you're getting is he gone
you're getting two free tickets to the
UFC [ __ ] match punch strong oh you
[ __ ] asian chick you gotta bring an
asian chick to get the [ __ ] tickets
but if you're bringing asian chick you
are getting two free tickets to the live
show are you cool with that Jay I mean
really 215 million goes to taxes listen
to the show you don't know what the
[ __ ] gonna happen you don't know where
the news is crazy it's crazy your fans
are really knowledgeable about code
though they are [ __ ] on the beat
about what's going on I love it if the
Lakers went back to the forum
oh they're thinking about that right
because they want to do they're trying
to [ __ ] with the Clippers how would they
[ __ ] with power gamers are gonna open
arena in [ __ ] Inglewood
they're both just ditching the font
center a couple games at the staple side
by the way I went to the Staples Center
on Sunday it sucks that I hate to stay
honest I hate it makes zero what's wrong
with it makes zero sense what's wrong
it's just a shitty [ __ ] arena I've
been to a lot of Reena let's talk about
what you're comparing to your Cleveland
arena right where nobody has anything
going on in their lives oh this is the
biggest moment of the thing so they act
really excited when we're stuck in
traffic
make it Hollywood dreams come true bang
intends and [ __ ] doing the best blow
in the world so we don't compare to your
Cleveland are you talking about the
atmosphere or that I'm talking about the
atmosphere I'm talking about the world
fear the arena they look of it the
acoustics had a common sense already
miss J breaking news I miss it
calling Jay with some more news yeah
miss Ferrett they're saying the Staples
Center is a dope Stadium no it's week
let me not say what's your argument
massive snow Madison Square Garden
Philly I've been to a bunch of stadiums
before it that one stinks United's I
totally agree not it centers way better
yes Madison Square Garden of course the
cards room and Nadi would call him some
new rumors when did the basketball
playoffs start two weeks three weeks
baby weeks go around the horn who's
gonna win the NBA Finals okay easily we
don't have to go around the horn let's
just everybody say the east to the
finals that's what our Raptors yeah I
think that's a good I like I like the
Sixers thing I like the Sixers right now
I like the Sixers dude I think they
could make the finals I think Jimmy
Butler is just he's just [ __ ] causes
problems everywhere he goes he just
hates everybody I don't know I don't
feel it I don't feel it right now as a
Sixers fan I don't think he's right I
mean may know I'm being slowly become
one of my favorite players in the Beast
no way he hit some people are saying
he's starting to turn the corner
Jimmy Butler who's that J breaking news
that's from Jay in Anaheim
I don't mind Jimmy Butler right now I
mean even if he's like when he were that
when they when they came out that he was
talking [ __ ] about the coaching and the
rotations it was true okay it was true
yeah but he had some watch himself cuz
this yeah I got angry third team he
might give a girl can ran out on I agree
that he should probably keep it internal
or whatever but Brett Brown is not a
great coach and I could see the
frustration and in a good basketball
player watching Brett Brown you know
[ __ ] lose 20-point leads and
constantly just like [ __ ] scrubbing
up the third quarter with like a great a
great team you know a team has a lot of
talent the Sixers have a lot of talent
when two four three two four four four
four six yeah I mean like you don't
altum Utley want that to be the BIOS I
know I know but then again you see if
that was Brett Browns offense was a put
him on the corner three it's ridiculous
it's so dumb it's ridiculous don't even
get me started on Brett Brown he's one
of the worst [ __ ] coaches I've ever
watched like III don't get it you got
this Joe and beat-beat he's like a
[ __ ] Tim Duncan type you know he
cannot be stopped in the paint period
yeah
period he's got why would you put that
guy anywhere near the three-point he's
got a soft touch to anywhere the guy can
shoot he can [ __ ] in he can post dudes
up he can he can dribble he can beat you
off the dribble he could he's got moves
just get him the [ __ ] ball down low
period that's the end of the story on
this [ __ ] stupid pick-and-roll
[ __ ] by the way Collin Sexton is the
speaking of Tim Duncan is the first top
20 player to get 23 points or more in
six straight contest games I just read
that very well very hard
break your illiteracy come from so it
was horrible many heart attacks each
word dribbling right there that was a
great game and that was a great game
yeah I mean we're gonna get that in the
playoff
hopefully you know when are the playin
games is that today I say Duke I mean I
say dude
and I hope that go far cuz I really do
want to watch him play Gonzaga I like
that too the girl won as well aren't
they going to seek Tennessee what are
then were they mad I got a key and a
fire
telephone santa kai okay i don't know
what that was oh don't stuff in there
for that first ever wow what's the call
what's the call back to the penalty box
he's probably got to take a piss look
he's gone right out that door grabbed
all nine of his phones in his laptop
he's going right outside he's leaving
wow what a turn of events you guys need
to come up with some kind of hand
signals you know like a mumble jumble
for what for the penalties you know that
oh I see what you mean you're watching
them if you're watching hockey they got
hooking slashing hey speaking like
what's that like karate chopping
personal foul personal foul yeah like
you know I just know hooking speaking of
punch-drunk sports is there any update
on skank fest is that happening I am
from what I understand yes I already
said we were last week
oh he said that personally yeah he said
that do we were all right so we'll see
we'll see I'll talk to him this week
though because there are people sending
tweets and [ __ ] I know a lot of people
already bought it sad threats a lot of
death threats coming in threats but yeah
but they haven't they haven't said like
what day we would be doing or podcast
but we did it last year we should be
doing it this year as well all right as
far as I know that's not breaking ice
Jay talked about it you know Jay from
Anaheim if you can call in Jay might
know let us know about anybody knows it
might be it might be Jay yeah
what is the Johnny what are the playin
games as therefore playing games is that
right wow that's a big play in game st.
John's and Arizona State usually it's
like these weird crazy school yes a
John's big team Belmont so far I'm
pulling for Belmont then Farley
Dickinson that's what I'm rooting for
then that school is so small they only
have four starters the IRA for the small
schools every time it's of course
brackets never do not so that's why I
want Duke to win that's really ever you
know what I mean gives them enough
credit that's why it's always fun the
tournaments always functions it's always
those little schools to catch magic go
to the Brody Stephens hotline you're on
with punch-drunk yeah guys what's up
brother we haven't talked to any UFC yet
what do you got what's going on Mike
Trout no I don't know about this deal
you guys heard about but UFC sign an
extension for two years with ESPN and
that ESPN plus is going to hold all
their paper views from now on oh is that
right
yeah it is so so they won't even have if
you have the Internet going through the
internet now that's it Wow these
networks are going down so that they're
you're saying to- anymore pay-per-views
huh yeah oh here it is right here Wow he
makes ESPN so right it makes that for
all pay-per-view of rights they're gonna
they're gonna that's what they're gonna
have now they're gonna be able to buy it
on there like on their Smart TV or
whatever you know there's all everyone's
gonna be in a bar looking at their
smartphone
oh let's go ESPN Plus will be an app and
like you know when you have a smart TV
you get your apps it's just like
connected
it's gonna be the way of the future hi
guys it's just the way it is make sure
y'all come back dead it just makes sense
because that's the that's what is
happening you know even if you go to
like most people watch HBO on HBO go or
a streaming version of so ESPN is just
going to a streaming service ESPN plus
it's just gonna be a different way to
get the same so said it says it'll be 60
bucks for the paper views each
pay-per-view yep what was it normally
what was it normally what's a normal
pay-per-view cost not that I guess about
that but they're not as condor not as
often and they're not always they're not
always pay-per-view right and they're
trying to get it to be pay-per-view
every time every time yeah well main pay
per view every number of pay-per-view
event like the next I think starts next
month it's gonna be on ESPN plus so you
have to sign up for ESPN plus Beta extra
five bucks and then you can no discount
off the pay-per-view a finalist Wow so
you have to sign up and be a member of
ESPN Plus and then pay the the
pay-per-view price I [ __ ] told you
right Wow well you know what I'm happy
to say that I don't give a [ __ ] about
the UFC
I like how I like oh this shows gonna
blow up I like how Dana White says it
like we're supposed to be excited about
yeah he's like dude I got great news for
you financially [ __ ] you lose a bunch of
money and get to if you want to watch
people get knocked out you're in luck
you're gonna get [ __ ]
here's modulation that's your money out
of your pocket you're like oh guys I got
a great announcement this huge UFC butt
plug is going right up your ass so why
didn't think I want to surprise didn't
do their own network like the WWE where
they can just you know you sign up 9 no
they did they do have they
yeah it's a better suit it's a better
deal for them with the SPN that's a big
[ __ ] reach you know you knew this was
gonna have court and of course it didn't
take long how long was that one month a
year a year now that's actually breaking
news that guy called in that way now it
is breaking it breaking news that is
look breaking news [ __ ] what's his name
from Anaheim this guy works for UFC
that's exactly what we said was gonna
happen yeah it makes sense but it's it's
just a bad deal for fans right yeah and
it locks you in the [ __ ] ESPN stupid
[ __ ] it's just a way that now your
credit cards got to get hit from ESPN
every [ __ ] month if I want to watch
UFC it all at all
[ __ ] that it's like for the casual fan I
do watch it once in a while what am I
supposed to do I guess go to a friend's
house but it's like I'm not gonna pay a
month [ __ ] subscription to watch you
eat it was so much better at the app
simonec good I mean you're still getting
advertised you get commercials like what
the last GOC fight that was happening on
Saturday with a fight night they're
still commercials and between the fight
Wow like so you're still getting
advertising even though you're paying
for advertising to get ticket sales they
get endorsements and then on top of that
they're trying to [ __ ] the [ __ ] and we
pay to watch advertising now of course
suck money and they got the monster
energy check money and everybody it's
money at every angle suck my dick I'm
gonna get the Spike TV app even though
it's not around anymore [ __ ] man that's
that sucks that's terrible news well
congratulations you SPN you're making a
lot more money [ __ ] [ __ ] hey I
don't know how long it's gonna last
though I mean it really that's I think
absolutely I think I think it hurts I
think it hurts the brand I think it's
it's kids not it's good preventing new
fans thank you fans
it definitely turns me off as like a
casual finger I'm not gonna watch I mean
I'll go to a friend's house obviously
well I've always been like that UFC I
don't think I paid one penny I've never
paid really that upset I'm not upset
about it but I feel bad for watching
ESPN next year watch ESPN next year you
have to get ESPN Plus
to play fantasy football something like
that oh yeah if they could they would oh
of course
all about I mean UFC he's just extremely
excited to [ __ ] really lock down a
monopoly with the biggest sports
provider and really just pigeonhole fans
into having to buy this monthly
subscription I wish I could give ESPN
everything that I have yeah
just drunk just load everything I
haven't taken right to [ __ ] angry ESPN
ago have it all take everything I have
the SPN just show me a good dunk once in
a while
please stop showing handicapped children
missing three-pointers and they're also
I bet they start jamming more of a
political agenda into it if I see one
more three-year-old with cancer running
for a kickoff return for a touchdown
while real adults act like they can't
tackle this kid he's right there
hit him there's no way this kid's got
moves like that yeah bro what's your
favorite team that's how you do a phone
call
God well yeah that's really bad news
that pisses me off you know it's just
more [ __ ] capitalistic [ __ ]
garbage let's just go down looks like it
just went down really apparently for the
next one looks like that's a sycamore it
you're gonna have to do the ESPN plus
they're gonna have to figure that out
every goddamn bar is gonna have to
[ __ ] figure that out what yeah yeah
well if I mean it's such a big thing
like that's what people do they go to
supports bars and watch the fights of
course yeah yeah yeah no if I don't get
it at home I do it that way yeah man I
can't believe [ __ ] Trevor Cruz died
well I'm glad he's dead yeah did you
hear about that Sam
Sam the most trusting person of all time
so what is it you said you had something
your bail and you never unveiled it that
says I do yoga eight one eight you got
it yes
push and believe we have fun I'm a good
guy blue-collar Jewish enjoy it yes and
where did you get that poster he got it
at Bette DSi for all of your poster
needs all do a caveman coffee ad because
last night I drank a caveman coffee when
I was producing killed Tony get that
phone call out of here you're on the air
with punch room that up posters made by
my good friend Scott Sandra everybody on
it
6:02 thank you Scott for making that
poster what do you have to say what's up
buddy yeah you interrupted my caveman
Coughlin's caveman coffee dot-com good
caveman come over yeah and what's that
[ __ ] rapes and I was good if you go
to our the bracket challenge yeah just
go to punch honks Twitter we've been
retreating it Anthony Johnson set it up
so get in there and get all your
brackets going and fill it up we would
haven't discussed we'll figure out what
somebody's gonna win whoever does it
usually I do pretty well and then like
like Jeff sees for that like I feel like
b-dubs is gonna kind of have a problem
with it because they all have like they
don't have those Smart TVs
oh good cuz I have a lot of bars are
gonna have problems with this [ __ ]
ESPN I [ __ ] hate Buffalo Wild Wings
or food it sucks their sponsor [ __ ] them
I don't give a [ __ ] that's got to be a
penalty wait
it's gotta be a pet hold on it's alright
ah to be home live in the penalty box
buy you lunch there [ __ ] that there's
food sucks or wings or rubbery the
cheeseburger every thing saw surprise
they like the [ __ ] Hooters is overrated
to their table 17 year old girls that
are half-naked what they do at Hooters
they're 10 years too old yeah that's my
opinion
where's it's 35 year old women I hope
this gets back to Buffalo Wild Wings
tweet at them put my name in the tweet
say I think they [ __ ] sucks their food
sucks it's overpriced
you ever had a salad at Buffalo it's a
war salad ever then how would you go to
Buffalo Wild that's a penalty in the box
[ __ ] get in the box
get a salad at Buffalo Wild Wings
everything okay so the only thing left
but you've been there a zillion times in
high they got the [ __ ] TVs the TVs
are great that's all you ever have a
salad at McDonald's is horrible why I
ate everything else and I hate it as
like well the last thing left on the
menus is [ __ ] salad it stinks whole
thing stinks this episode has been
brought to you by Buffalo Wild Wings go
there for all of your Buffalo needs
anyway I drank a [ __ ] caveman coffee
last night around 8 p.m. I didn't go to
bed until 6 a.m. so caping coffees
pretty [ __ ] good if you want to stay
awake on I like caveman coffee [ __ ]
Buffalo well [ __ ] is [ __ ] get a
bandana for free if you buy some fly fly
something buy something I bought
something once definitely got to Bly it
alright guys well thanks for listening
it's been a fantastic episode just as I
predicted
April 9th I'm dropping in on a vert ramp
just keep at me on instagram follow my
Instagram Chad zoo Maki you got it and
subscribe to my youtube everybody its
adventures in Argyle
can you change the dome though I can't
change the dough name can you can you
help me with that job don't name the
dough name did he say don't name is this
guy Jesus we got to close the show
anyway there's no panel
thank you oh yeah I get that that for
free somewhere right yeah if you're cold
Jason Tebow calm those Sixers go Cavs